somebody who's like me not been at
school for a while i'm sure he won't
mind me saying that he's the mayor of
greater manchester under the morning
morning nice to see you back home oh
yeah
yeah i feel like you're enjoying i am i
am hi ladies we're going to chat to you
as well
what do you make of what the minister
said yesterday oh my goodness um they're
coming on telly aren't they ministers
one after another i'm just showing they
don't really understand what's going on
the idea that people can just uh oh get
more hours it's easy they're actually
working all hours at godsends anyway or
get a better job i mean it's just not in
the real world if you talk to people in
this
area um and then you've got the fellow
last week saying all 30p is fine if
they're just going to cook properly
it's one after another and they haven't
got a handle on what's going on now in
people's homes and people's lives yeah
so they've got a chance today to support
a windfall tax which i think they should
so they can do something for everyone's
energy goals but i would say to them
just you know get that uplifting
universal credit back give people
something now for those who are most
struggling it just looks to me like they
are just just flailing around trying to
blame the public in some way or lecture
the public it's just wrong there's no
money tree though you know is what they
would say if i was trying to defend the
government i would say you know what are
they going to do they've only got a
finite amount of cash
well these are exceptional times and you
can't so where they get the money from
people in your poll today what is it two
in five people say they're skipping
meals yeah yeah what what's the health
impact of that or you know for kids uh
if they're doing that sometimes you just
have to step in and help people but
they say no money tree the energy
companies are making massive profits you
know windfall level profits why not
support a windfall tax today in the
house of commons labour a right to bring
that vote today and all parties should
back it that lady's nodding here i know
you you'll take some questions
just tell us your name so that people
and i do quite a bit of
chatting around the community and two of
the things that came up this week when i
mentioned that you were coming was
around the greenhouse
and also
the 13 that were paired
and i suppose in tampa like this we're
talking about this this crisis that
we've got
what is the actual impact that you can
have on either of those things if you're
out of time so on the clean air zone i
absolutely understand what you're saying
this was something that government asked
us to do we had no choice we had to do
something about uh air quality because
we've got problems in certain places
it's a gate it's breaching the law you
know obviously that impacts on kids
health however we tried
and then when all of the issues hit with
the
cost of living situation we're dealing
with we recognized it was unworkable and
we went back to the government earlier
this year and said that it's unworkable
and we've now proposed to the government
a non-charging clean air zone what that
means is for those who want to upgrade
their vehicle they will get help to
upgrade their vehicle but it won't be
done by charging everybody that well
that's what we've proposed and we're
waiting to hear from the government on
my role my brother i can't understand
what you're saying but let me just give
you a direct example about how i think i
can help you and people across the wigan
borough where i live as well i have
taken the decision to put buses here
back under public control we've had 35
years 36 years of total
free-for-all with the private bus
companies charging what they like i'm
gonna introduce in wigan next year a two
pound cap on adult bus fares
and that i think will make a real
difference to people
and you've got a question haven't you
yes yeah this is uh i'm angela angela i
am part of northern art and so
i just want to start with a quote from
john trontor who says that when we
understand kurt we'll have to redefine
democracy
and the basic of any good society
that understands kurt is that everybody
has enough and everybody can afford to
pay the bills and what we seem to be
stuck in is this political system
whereby we have the tories you take away
and then labor we sometimes overserve
and to get through that then we've got
to find different ways of working
together and stop that wealth extraction
that is enabling power companies to have
it over the barrel
and also look at how we shift resource
directly to families around ubi so when
you're a role as murderer across greater
manchester outside that political system
what can we do to increase and encourage
community power and community welfare
first on the big book about the
political system i am absolutely clear
westminster
doesn't work it's dysfunctional it
doesn't work for the north of england i
think the westminster system that we've
had has created the north-south divide
to be honest so some if you're going to
close that something fundamentally
different is needed and i personally
would support
proportional representation uh for the
commons to create a different way of
working um between the parties on your
specific
universal basic income is ubi
i think this is an idea whose time has
come why
you know you all know and and i know
living here over the years people living
in this area the wigan borough have had
to kind of take on more and more
insecurity when it comes to their work
you know the culture of
zero hours casual hours people doing
three jobs and then they're spending
every hour worrying because they won't
be able to get the rent you know so
they're living on the edge and that
damages people's people's health a
universal basic income would put a solid
foundation beneath everybody so they
could have a life with security stop
worrying about everything you know come
out through a kobe pandemic but we've
got a mental health pandemic now haven't
we because so many people are living so
close to the edge all of the time and
we've got to take that away and give
them much more uh much more
security in their everyday everyday
lives and a universal basic income would
do that and we'd stop spending so much
money picking up the pieces of failure
because you've set people up to succeed
rather than the benefit system which is
constantly in my views trying to trip
them up and make them fail ladies i'm
going to have to steal the mayor away
and we've got another question on the
other table if you don't mind thanks
very much oh price rising yeah
rising how do i how do you experience to
cover this crisis
honestly i i hear it everywhere i go i
was in salford a couple of weeks ago and
a food bank there said to me that
they're not giving out frozen food
anymore because everyone's turned their
freezers off you know because anything
that's got ongoing energy
yeah so
it's real and it's happening now
i would say to the government they've
got to do something now stop making
excuses stop blaming the public that 20
pound uplift in universal credit that we
had during the pandemic should come back
and come back straight away because
people are struggling right now and you
know we can't have this thing the
minister's coming on to kay's program
saying oh work more hours or get a
better
yesterday what was your thought on that
yes but yeah yeah
tell me what the difference 20 pounds
would make to you it's going to help
because like me as a single parents i'm
working hard to try to make up
everything and if they bring that 10
pounds it go a long way
yeah i mean i i just think they should
should do that they've
not to me got a grip on the situation at
the moment it's it's changing now for
people isn't it with the prices and cost
of energy i would do the universal
credit uplift now giving help to those
most needed and then the windfall tax
which they should also do would help
everybody with their energy bills ahead
of october and i think those are two
things that they could announce now that
would take away a lot of the worry
from people who are just now thinking
how am i going to get through this year
okay i'm afraid we're out of time
hopefully that was useful
we really appreciate you taking the time
thanks very much we'll leave you to it
and we'll hopefully see you again soon
you will thanks a lot thanks